[Musik]
[Applaus]
vierter und paypal fordert
das business online dating boomt aber
was macht das mit uns die machen ihren
job richtig gut keine ahnung wie das
sonst sagen soll aber ja die ups machen
süchtig wie verändert sich das
zusammenleben unserer gesellschaft diese
möglichkeit so schnell neue leute kennen
zu lernen wirkt einfach auch ein großes
risiko
bleibt dabei die romantik auf der
strecke ich finde aber auch nicht
schlimm zu sagen später hey ich habe
meinen mann über eine dating ab
kennengelernt
[Musik]
also ich benutze dating apps tatsächlich
weil ich auf der suche nach der liebe
bin weil ich gerne lieber finden möchte
das ist ein großes ziel das weiß ich und
vielleicht kommt dazwischen ein anderer
zustand aber so das ist so dass
das
ultimo würde ich sagen
[Musik]
anna ich bin 33 jahre alt ich denke seit
so zehn jahren online glaube ich diana
hat eine ganze generation das dating
leben ins internet verlagert während sie
die große liebe sucht haben andere
userinnen ganz andere motivationen ob
beziehung schneller sex freundschaften
oder ego booster das netz bietet raum
für unterschiedlichste bedürfnisse
zweiten liegt einfach im trend jede und
jeder dritte der 30 bis 49 jährigen in
deutschland hat dating plattformen schon
einmal genutzt und deswegen hat es das
internet auch auf platz zwei der
häufigsten orte zum kennenlernen
geschafft
anna muss ihre suche also nicht auf
deutschland beschränken sie kann mobil
arbeiten und hat sich für paris
entschieden die stadt der liebe hier
hofft sie auf ihr liebesglück ich glaube
die meisten leute würden eher naiv sagen
aber ich bin hier in paris eben auch um
eventuell
partner zu finden ja hier die liebe zu
finden in der stadt die ich liebe das
wäre so jerry runde kate nur dann denke
ich mir ist es gut auch bei außerhalb
seiner babbel zu schauen und deswegen
das macht online dating auch so
interessant für mich ich lernen leute
kennen die ich vielleicht sonst nicht
kennenlernen würde und dann ist es im
online dating kosmos natürlich schön zu
sehen dass es recht viel auswahl gibt
und dass man sich nicht mit
dem abfinden muss was man gerade hat
sondern auch sagen kann hey das tut mir
nicht gut und ich weiß auch wenn es
jetzt gerade schwer ist aber
da wird schon jemand anderes kommen
der einfach besser passt ich nutze
derzeit bumble kinder und hin und
ich kann gar nicht sagen wo ich mich am
wohlsten fühle weil ich glaube dass
dinge ist dass ich drei apps ab zeigt
schon dass keine perfekte online dating
ist ein gigantischer wachstumsmarkt
live cells und das seit den 50er jahren
es gab schon immer partnervermittlung
das upgrade digitalisierung lässt die
kassen jetzt so richtig klingeln
experten schätzen dass in deutschland
die umsätze diverser plattformen bis
2024 auf und 235 millionen euro steigen
der all time favorite ist tender allein
seit 2012 wurde die app weltweit mehr
als 450 millionen mal heruntergeladen
das resultat insgesamt mehr als 65
milliarden matches seit der gründung
sagt zumindest händler hinter kinder
steckt die matchball der marktführer
besitzt neben sozialen netzwerken und
singlebörsen die acht größten dating
marken der welt neben kinder sind es
unter anderem ok cupid und hedge die mch
group bedient diverse zielgruppen und
dominiert damit auch den markt ok cupid
hat eine erweiterte auswahl an optionen
für geschlecht orientierung und
identität
die mch group ist längst an der börse wo
mit der liebe gezockt wird aber
natürlich versucht nicht nur dieser
konzern die herzen der userinnen zu
erobern weitere big player die
aktiengesellschaft babelsberg networks
und die parship meet group die zum
prosieben konzern gehört und alle wollen
vor allem eins geld verdienen und uns an
sie binden aber passt das überhaupt
zusammen wirtschaftliche interessen und
die suche nach liebe platz und dating da
gibt es sicher nicht konflikte zwischen
dem interesse der plattform eben
möglichst nette leute dazu haben und dem
was eigentlich doch bei beziehungen
wichtig wäre dass man wirklich auch mit
seinen speziellen spleenigen oder
vielleicht auch radikalen unangenehmen
seiten auch sich wechselseitig
kennenlernt weil verflixt nochmal in
einer beziehung muss man auch damit
irgendwie klarkommen können aber dafür
gibt es eben keinen raum in diesen
plattformen weil es so eine
wohlfühlatmosphäre sein soll weil davon
lebt die plattform aber es ist
eigentlich nicht im interesse ihrer
nutzerinnen und nutzer
ich bin alex ich bin 36 ich bin
journalist und er stellte manchmal nein
ich mache das weil man die easy peasy
und sehr schnell leute kennenlernen kann
ohne dass man jetzt in groß erst in der
bar oder mit club sich traumes und ich
finde es eine gute möglichkeit um
einfach das mal neben weit zu machen und
viele leute kennen zu sagen das ist
natürlich eine spannende frage die man
als nutzer handy sich fragt wie
funktioniert die app ist die jetzt
überhaupt bereit und das möglichst
schnell seinen traumpartner anzeigt oder
verdienste ja nicht eigentlich damit
geld dass ich möglichst lange niemals
geöffnet also was sind die algorithmen
dahinter
ich bin - ich beschäftige mich mit big
data künstlicher intelligenz
ein algorithmus ist am ende nichts
anderes als ein kleines monster ziehen
das futter benötigt und dieses futter
sind eben die information die ich an
gebe algorithmen sind also die
heimlichen matchmaker die suche nach
liebe wird zur programmieraufgaben
zahlenkolonnen stadt schmetterlinge im
bauch die daten dafür stellen wir selbst
zur verfügung wer uns am ende aus dem
riesigen pool an möglichkeiten angezeigt
wird ist also kein zufall sondern
mathematik jeder dating anbieter hat
unterschiedliche algorithmen die er
verwendet und die meisten geben das auch
nicht preis bei kinder
wird verstärkt auf das aussehen gesetzt
indem ich bilder von mehr hochladen ohne
große biografie schreiben und
dementsprechend funktioniert der
algorithmus da ganz anders weil auch
viel mit bilderkennung gearbeitet wird
und auch anhand der user interaktion ob
ich jetzt zum beispiel nach rechts oder
links geschaut werde und je nachdem wie
beliebte ich auf der plattform basierend
auf meiner attraktivität erhalte ich auf
mehr matches dann gibt es natürlich auch
gegenbewegung durch online dating apps
wie okcupid oder auch monsanto
cupid setzt weniger auf die
attraktivität und mehr auch auf
charaktereigenschaften indem sie ganz
viele
personalisierte fragen stellen zur
politischen einstellungen religion
vorlieben zur literatur und kultur
kinder hat anfangs ein attraktivitäts
algorithmus verwendet den sogenannten e
loskow hohe punktzahl große chance auf
das liebesglück
ursprünglich wurde der eu score
entwickelt um die spielstärke von
schachspieler innen zu bewerten was hat
es für das online dating damals bedeutet
meiner seite
wenn ich zum beispiel gezeigt werde von
jemandem der eine so genannte 10 ist
dann bin ich rapide beliebt auf kinder
als wenn ich ein match erhalte von einer
person die mit einer sogenannten 3
bewertet wird beziehungsweise als
weniger beliebt oder attraktiv geld und
genau so funktioniert dieser rosskur
weswegen er auch immens unter kritik
steht bei beliebtheit wiederum seinen
ursprung hat auf die definition von norm
schöner attraktivität
heute verwendet händler den helios gar
nicht mehr schreibt das unternehmen
stattdessen soll jetzt unsere online
aktivität in den apps der garant für ein
passendes match sein raffiniert denn das
ziel der unternehmen ist ja nicht dass
wir uns schon nach einem swype verlegen
sondern dass wir möglichst lange online
bleiben je länger wir dort sind desto
mehr einnahmen für die dating dienste
durch abos und werbung nicht nur die
algorithmen fesseln uns an dating ups
auch deren design basiert auf einem
psychologischen prinzip der variablen
belohnung was dabei genau passiert schon
die erwartung einer belohnung löst bei
uns im gehirn die ausschüttung von
dopamin aus wenn wir zweiter wird unser
glückshormon aktiviert zur vermehrten
ausschüttung
dann durch ein match aber auch die reine
hoffnung darauf macht uns schon
glücklicher verrückt oder eigentlich
wird dieses prinzip beim glücksspiel
eingesetzt und jetzt eben auch bei der
liebe so ein dopamin rausch ist jedoch
leider schnell wieder vorbei gut für die
apps denn deswegen wollen wir gleich
weiter zweiter je mehr desto besser für
die dating dienste denn sie leben davon
natürlich sind sie auch daran
interessiert dass user tatsächlich die
liebe finden viele erfolgreiche matches
steigern schließlich das image der apps
und bringen neue kundinnen
was macht online dating mit den nutzer
innen ich bin katharina ich bin seit
letzter woche ist 27 jahre alt und ich
wohne in berlin zusammen mit meiner frau
und unseren mittlerweile drei hunden
also ich hatte so in der hochphase
gerade nicht das gefühl dass da
wirkliche menschen hinter sind aber auch
weil es so viele waren ich glaube das
war eben auch als ich heterosexuell
gedatet haben war da einfach unendliche
auswahl es hat nie aufgehört das stand
nie du bist jetzt am ende und deswegen
war es dann irgendwie selbst wenn du
dich mal verpasst war so ach naja so in
20 menschen kommt wieder einer der mir
gefällt was katharina mainz nennt sich
bei sovello effekt also kann das warten
nicht nur süchtig machen sondern auch
einen nachhaltigen effekt auf uns als
gesellschaft haben nämlich dass wir uns
schwerer entscheiden können oder frau dr
degen
ich bin dagegen
ich bin sozial psychologin und
paartherapeutin und forscher zum mobilen
online dating und liebe es gibt da eine
neue parallelität im dating und was
bedeutet dass man mehrere dales auch im
lager innerhalb einer woche zum beispiel
haben kann oder sogar an einem abend
oder sich das nächste date über kinder
unterm tisch oder auf zuletzt besorgt
wenn es nicht so läuft das hat mehrere
konsequenzen auf das man sich wie
negativ kennenlernen weil man es schnell
in reihe schalten kann
aber das ist auch so ein verletzungspech
zial
[Musik]
magali
sind so halt so viele optionen sind so
viel dating ups mann heißt halt nie
glücklich ja ich habe richtig schön
denkt gehabt zwar alles super die beiden
nach hause und eigentlich soll ich diese
finger weg erhalten von meinen dating
herbstanfang ich halt einfach wieder an
so zweiten und dann vergesse ich dass
das eigentlich super schön war ja was
mich halt mehr deshalb vielleicht sind
halt viel zu viele optionen und viel zu
viele menschen
hey ich bin nie ich komme aus england
und wind student und wohne seit fünf
jahren den kreiswerken
lenny hat nach einer trennung angefangen
online zu denken er genießt sein single
leben und hat beim dayton viel über sich
selbst und andere erfahren vor den
tricks der apps ist auch er nicht sicher
tina hat mich geprägt hat mich so
ausgetrickst zu machen weil als super
schlaugemacht ehrlich gesagt so dass
stets so wie viele leute dich licon man
kann ich sehen wenn ich geleitet hat
oder man was für andere tricks haben die
so mancher hat 102 bis sonntag und dann
ist man aus mit dem swaps und dann ist
man so ich möchte eigentlich mehr
erheben oder man 2 zurück und dann kann
man halten jetzt zurück zweiten wenn man
hat jemand falsch gezeigt hat irgendwie
so ist zum beispiel so wie ich spiele
eigentlich so und das ist und das macht
diese sucht und deswegen haben 15 euro
im monat aber ich hab's gemacht wenn ich
nicht mehr machen hinter der suche nach
der großen liebe steckt also big
business
die dating apps locken mit
vielversprechenden features und abo
modellen bei kinder kann man zur tender
plus gold oder platin upgraden und damit
laut unternehmen das flirt- und date
erlebnis verbessern je mehr man
investiert desto weniger werbung wird
angezeigt desto mehr likes und super
likes kann man vergeben zweitens scheint
plötzlich bequem und unbegrenzt
natürlich kann man die apps auch
kostenfrei nutzen doch so oder so zahlt
man in einer anderen währung ich zahl ab
dem moment eigentlich
den preis für die hoffnung auf liebe mit
meinen persönlichen informationen und
daten und genau so ist es eben wenn ich
nicht für eine dating eine
mitgliedschaft gebühr bezahlt da muss
ich mir als user doch die frage stellen
wie das unternehmen sich über wasser
halten kann
und ich glaub das ist im kopf vieler
menschen gar nicht angekommen weil wir
auch so verwöhnt sind was die nutzung
von social media betrifft wo wir keine
gebühren zahlen oder auch der konsum von
content wo wir zum beispiel auch nicht
gewillt sind das paypal abo
abzuschließen
diese plattform haben natürlich
incentive dahin dass die menschen nicht
lange zusammenbleiben und wieder
zurückkommen auf die plattform also da
könnte man über eine andere form der
monetarisierung nachdenken wie zum
beispiel man zahlt wenn man es geschafft
hat ein jahr lang zusammen zu bleiben
dann einen gewissen betrag aus mein name
ist christian hocks ich bin trend und
zukunftsforschung beschäftige mich
hauptsächlich generationsfrage unter
thematik der digitalisierung online
dating funktioniert vielleicht ohne
liebe aber nicht ohne kapitalismus
herzensangelegenheiten sorgen schon
immer für wirtschaftlichen erfolg aber
warum eigentlich keine ist mein name und
wir sind hier im institut für
sozialforschung ja ich habe ein projekt
gemacht hier zum thema online dating
wenn man sich mal anguckt so die
geschichte der entwicklung des internets
ist es ja sehr sehr schwer gewesen bis
heute eigentlich sehr schwer für
irgendwas im internet geld zu nehmen und
dating plattform waren eigentlich mit
die ersten abonnement angebote für die
leute wirklich bereit waren auch eine
ganze menge geld in monatlichen abo zu
bezahlen klar war das schon relativ
bewusst dass das unternehmen hinter
steckt aber wenn es den zweck erfüllt
was mir eigentlich egal
ich war fünf jahre mit meinem ex freund
zusammen wir haben uns dann getrennt
dann habe ich mir eingeredet jetzt denke
ich mal so ein bisschen haben ein
bisschen spaß zu studienzeiten hat
katharina ihr single leben voll
ausgekostet
aber mehr als an der oberfläche haben
ihre damaligen erfahrungen nicht
gekratzt es war auch ein bisschen hobby
kann man schon sagen ich habe damals in
wiesbaden mit meiner mitbewohnerin in
der wg gewohnt und wir waren beide
frisch getrennt und wir haben beide den
ganzen tag gehindert und es gab einen
morgen wo wir gerade bei anekdoten sind
ein morgen da haben wir uns in unserer
wg küche getroffen und dann hab ich
gesagt ach ja so und so ist gerade bei
mir und dann hat sie mich angeguckt sagt
ich hab auch besuche ich weiß nicht mehr
wieder heißt und dann haben wir uns
beide angeguckt und wir waren uns
überhaupt nicht mehr sicher wer da
eigentlich gerade in unseren betten
liegt weil wir einfach so in diesem
strudel waren dann war ich irgendwann
relativ schnell gelangweilt weil es halt
immer weiter ging und weil die gespräche
auch relativ flach waren was beim
online-dating schnell passiert ist dass
wir so eine checkbox lustig war wir
haben was wir uns wünschten und früher
hat man ja mal gesagt gut auf dem papier
aber hat mich gepasst und das scheint
fast vergessen zu haben weil jetzt
suchen wir so nach jemanden der soll
auch frühaufsteher sein auch veganer
bitte links grüne politik mögen schon im
ausland gewesen sein aber
oft wachsen wir ja über uns hinaus und
lernen was übers leben wenn wir jemanden
treffen wo wir gut zusammen passen
aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf
diese box niveau aber fördern diese
checkboxen nicht auch unsere
oberflächlichkeit und benachteiligen
menschen größere gesellschaftliche punkt
ist das natürlich die ganze
oberflächlichkeit kultur im netz so
entstanden ist man denke an instagram
kultur usw natürlich im dating dann noch
einmal maßgeblich am kritisiertes und
pflegen hat eine menge leute einfach aus
dem dating markt raus weil sie dort noch
keine chance haben online-dating kann
also durchaus dazu führen dass menschen
ausgegrenzt und auf ihr aussehen
reduziert werden doch sieht es offline
besser aus in einer bar sind es im
ersten moment schließlich auch er
äußerliche faktoren die jemanden dazu
bringen eine person anzusprechen
weswegen ich auch und unterständen nicht
unterschreiben würde das dating ist
total oberflächlich sind weil für mich
der kontakt in der bar zum beispiel
natürlich wann kriegt so die ganze
atmosphäre mit und den ganzen dehnt den
ganzen wald von einer person also nicht
nur jetzt das reine aussehen aber das
ist ist es schon sehr oberflächlich was
da passiert es gibt natürlich eine
gewisse dynamik das so einfach weil es
so ein massenphänomen ist und auch so
ähnlich strukturiert ist eigentlich
wieso shopping plattformen ja das halt
solche bilder und oberflächliche sprüche
ganz am anfang eine große rolle spielen
ja es erzeugt so ein bisschen eindruck
sich selber irgendwie so ein
millionenpublikum gegenüber quasi auch
auf eine bestimmte weise darzustellen
das ist sicherlich am anfang der fall
online-dating hat auch noch eine andere
dimension wenn diese online
kommunikation dann wirklich mal anfängt
wie schnell ist dann wirklich auch sehr
persönlich werden die leute sich sachen
erzählen gerade war es auch so ein
bisschen so ein safe space ist sachen
erzählen die sie vielleicht im face to
face kontakten in der bar oder so würden
nicht am ersten abend erzählen aber es
kann dann auch sehr schnell sehr
persönlich werden sich schnell so
intensiv aufeinander einzulassen bietet
sicherlich potenzial für tiefgehende
verbindungen doch die online dating welt
ist nicht nur rosarot es gibt auch
negative folgen wie das ghosting bei dem
der kontakt ohne vorwarnung und
erklärung abrupt abgebrochen das
gegenüber komplett ignoriert wird das
hinterlässt spuren
[Musik]
das ist die kehrseite dessen das dass
das internet auch als unsichere raum
wahrgenommen wird man auch sich schnell
wieder zurückziehen kann wenn es eine
zunahme wird das bedeutet natürlich für
die andere person aussagen dass eben
also dann auch immer wieder so
plötzliche beziehungs abbrüche und das
dann einfach stille herrscht das finde
ich nicht was wenn ich respektlos der
anderen gegen personen gegenüber und ich
finde es vollkommen in ordnung dann zu
schreiben haye aber kein weiter aber ich
wünsche dir alles gute weiterhin aber
ich will jetzt das match auflösen so was
zum beispiel also wenn man zum beispiel
gebürstet wird und man hatte schon immer
einen komplex wegen der eigenen nase
oder wegen der ja körpergröße wenn man
sehr groß ist ich zum beispiel oder
wegen korpulenz oder was man dann eben
für ein eigenes thema hat projiziert man
ins ghosting rein oft stimmt das aber
nicht also oft kosten menschen weil sie
überfordert sind die app gerade löschen
wollen gar nicht mehr denken wollen sich
verknallt haben oder viele gründe aber
meist nicht genau das thema was der
andere dem unterstellen aber
nichtsdestotrotz wird das dem
zugeschrieben und hat dann recht starke
auswirkungen auf das selbst und den
selbstwert das ist halt nicht cool aber
das passiert einfach so wenn man viel
ist glaube ich aber
jetzt versuche ich habe mein bestes das
nicht zu machen weil ich weiß wie das
wer tut ja ich finde online dating hat
mich ehrlich gemacht als mensch durch
meine verschiedenen erfahrungen das wird
mir jetzt wirklich helfen einfach
freilich in der beziehung zu sein und
das ist eigentlich ziemlich nicht so ja
deswegen bin ich eigentlich ziemlich
dankbar für diese ganzen online datings
als auch für alex liebesleben ist online
dating sehr wichtig er ist teil der lgbt
cube lars community noch heute erfährt
er deswegen wie viele andere
diskriminierung online dating ist für
ihn ein sicherer ort ich glaube kommen
bisschen drauf an also
meine freunde also been game meine
freunde auch da ist es total normal
einfach nicht mehr selber aus berlin
aber freunde von mir kommt von kleinen
dorf irgendwo und dann ist das die
einzige möglichkeit gewesen
gleichgesinnte zu treffen deswegen würde
ich sagen für die magic cube szene ist
das völlig normal sich online studenten
also gerade in der lgbt community ist
das glaube ich wichtig dass es diese
räume gibt was ihr einfach spaces sind
wenn ich irgendwie auch schon dorf lebe
in sachsen jetzt bis ins klischee pauli
aber und da einfach nicht so viele
andere games sind und wenn man in einem
hippen clubs an und wie ein anspricht
gibt es genau aufs maul wie man das
vielleicht auch nicht riskieren also
insofern ist es glaube ich wichtig dass
das räume gibt wo leute egal wie sie
lieben und wen sie lieben eben auch
diese räume haben ihre peergroup
kennenzulernen ja also so ein safe space
ich meine das gilt also in der
homosexuellen community natürlich diese
online dating apps sehr sehr viel
verändert das hat sich sehr verschoben
ins internet und das ist wichtig dass es
solche orte geht wo man eben auch frei
von von gesellschaftlicher
diskriminierung von anna leuten die ein
irgendwie bedrohungen oder angreifen
oder auch nur kritisieren dass man sich
dort treffen können
für katharina ist online dating
ebenfalls ein safe space ein ort wo sie
frei und unkompliziert nach liebe suchen
konnte habe sehr lange männer getötet
und da fehlt mir relativ leicht neue
männer kennenzulernen es war gar kein
problem und dann hat sich irgendwann für
mich selbst beschlossen habe dass sich
frauen leiten möchte war das nicht mehr
so easy und dann hab ich ja kinder
angefangen zu nutzen habe viel geändert
viel gedatet und hab dann als ich nach
berlin gezogen bin bei einer
besichtigung auch gehindert und hatte
ein match mit meiner jetzigen frau ich
bin jetzt seit zwei jahren verheiratet
glücklich verheiratet seit fünf jahren
und meiner frau zusammen und wir sind ja
das perfekte beispiel dass es geht happy
end für katharina aber wenn irgendwann
zu viele user innen vom dating markt
verschwinden geht das geschäftsmodell
der apps nicht mehr auf immer neue ideen
müssen her um unsere herzen zu erobern
gar nicht so einfach in unserer
schnelllebigen welt
dieses upgrade aber könnte unser
bisheriges online dating leben ganz
schön auf den kopf stellen vielleicht
sogar revolutionieren das meta das
klingt nach zukunftsmusik ist aber
vielleicht bald schon realität
insbesondere firmen die meta und
microsoft sehen darin die zukunft der
digitalen welt ein cyberspace bei dem
virtual reality augmented reality und
extended reality zusammen kommen also
eine welt voller 3d und simulationen
auch tender plant bereits das kinder was
hier sollen in zukunft die grenzen
zwischen online und offline verschwimmen
im historischen ist es so man setzt sich
da ins mittelmeer das rein mit seinem
digitalen avatar und trifft seine
digitale freundin dort oder ist keine
echte person es ist also im algorithmus
aber irgendein 1 bot dem mann
geschrieben hat dann gibt es da schon
ein paar nischen wie zum beispiel
einsamen menschen die sich nicht trauen
menschen echt physisch zu treffen wir
können sich damals an bord annähern und
dann ist es vielleicht auch einfacher
sich eine person zu treffen
die userinnen sollen sich in zukunft
gemeinsam in virtuellen räumen bewegen
und kennen lernen kann wie in einem
videospiel erwarten sie hier virtual
reality und augmented reality techniken
plus weitere features kinder coins mit
denen man virtuell boosten und
superleicht kaufen kann avatare
virtuelle experiences und vieles mehr
noch ist das kinderhaus in der planung
aber was es schon gibt interaktives
white nights dabei durchlebt man auf der
kinder app eine interaktive mystery
geschichte bei der man selbst
entscheidungen treffen muss diese
beeinflussen nicht nur die story sondern
auch potentielle matches man tauscht
sich über die geschichte aus wenn es
passt kann man weiter chatten wenn nicht
kommt der oder die nächste dating app
anbieter glauben an einen bedarf dafür
parship hat in einer befragung erhoben
das für mehr als ein drittel der
deutschen liebe auch gut ohne ein
menschliches gegenüber vorstellbar ist
insbesondere männer glauben an die
partielle liebe behauptet zumindest der
konzern aber wird das wirklich unsere
neue realität also noch kann das
natürlich kein ersatz für die realität
seines großen problem das wir haben ist
wir sind ja ein bisschen mehr als nur
unsere auditiver sinn und unsere
visueller sinn sondern wir sind die
ganze ganze menge mehr kannst viel
unterschwelliges unter bewusst ist dass
wir gar nicht spielen können ist ja auch
gar nicht genau verstehen das muss man
ehrlich sagen und das lässt sich
digitale meter wäre es nach wie vor
nicht simulieren also wirklich mal
geruch hin ja also insofern und ich
glaube man kann sagen das wird auch viel
geforscht dass menschen sich auch
gegenseitig die linken und dann auch
spüren ob sie sozusagen können passen
dass wir noch lange nicht gehen
standpunkt jetzt kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen
anna findet am dating meter was keinen
gefallen muss sie auch nicht denn sie
ist frisch verliebt direkt nach den
dreharbeiten ging es zu einem tender
date und etwas später hat es dann auch
richtig gefunkt ihr traum von der liebe
in paris ist wahr geworden
solange wir uns verlieben wollen wird
auch die geldmaschine dating app nicht
müde genauso wenig wie unsere finger
beim zweiten und ich kenne auch viele
die einfach angst haben alleine zu sein
aber dating hat mir geholfen zu sehen so
heldt sind so viele schöne supercoole
menschen in berlin und das ist was
tolles einfach single zu sein ist nicht
schlimm also ich glaube das
online-dating da schon großen einfluss
haben kann auch weil man ja mittlerweile
den radius sehr weit stellen kann und
letztendlich ist es doch auch irgendwie
viel schöner wenn man den perfekten
partner überall auf der welt findet als
wenn man sich mit dem hi perfekten oder
viertel perfekten zufrieden gibt weil
die person nah dran wohnt der erste
moment ist natürlich trotzdem aufregend
weil du ja gestik und mimik und so alles
vorher beim schreiben nicht so richtig
mitbekommt und wenn man sich dann trifft
ist es schon einmal spannend wer der
andere dann genau ist und ob man auch
entweder die chemie trotzdem noch spürt
für mich sind die apps nun weg um
jemanden kennenzulernen und dann offline
richtig kennenzulernen so es ist eine
eintrittskarte
aber nicht die ganze show was für die
einen die eintrittskarte ist ist für die
unternehmen wissen es
die tun alles dafür um ihr profitables
geschäftsmodell weiter zu optimieren
die liebe wird mehr und mehr zur
geldmaschine und verschiebt sich in den
digitalen raum aber online dating ist
eine wechselbeziehung die wirtschaft
beeinflusst unser miteinander und wir
den markt das kennenlernen ist einfacher
geworden und zugleich komplizierter
unsere suche nach der liebe hat sich
verändert und wird dies in zukunft noch
stärker tun trotz der risiken ist online
dating eine chance für die liebe und für
neue verbindungen auf die wie offline
nicht gekommen wäre
[Musik]